my guest tonight was a cast member on
star not live for five seasons she is
the creator
executive producer writer and star of
the new
tbs series chad please welcome
naseem padrad how are you i'm great
thanks for being here in person
i know so so lovely to have you you look
absolutely incredible
thank you i i don't know why when when
someone as beautiful as you is wearing
something matte white i want to spill a
bowl of marinara sauce
go for it no and it's nothing i swear to
god it's not hostile
i just want to have a big bowl and come
over to hug you and then have it
right isn't that the yeah that's not at
all hostile
[Laughter]
i swear it's coming from just the
aesthetic andy
oh my gosh you really blend into that
crowd i didn't even see you
i know good to see you i'm very
two-dimensional
[Laughter]
spiritually intellectually he was
vaccinated he was one of the first
people in the united states vaccinated
uh like as a tesla but i'm regardless of
vaccination i'm allergic to the smell of
cheese
[Laughter]
surrounded by supportive people
no it start it started when we had to be
distanced and just kind of like
there's extra cushions on this seat i'm
all set up out right i've got my station
that thing truckers use to urinate
yep you've got all those trucker devices
wait urinate
yeah well there is that other device no
you look absolutely fantastic and i
cannot tell you
what a delight it is to talk to you in
person ever so many people do zoom now
but people are starting to trickle in
now
and i don't know about you i miss
humanity so much not all humanity
because some people are dreadful yes
um we won't go into names but you know
let's get into some names
yeah but um but i have to say uh just
having you
hear what's it like for you because
i know that you're someone that for
years you know in new york city
you're a performer you love crowds how
are you handling the no crowds aspect of
this whole thing
it's been tough yeah i'm excited to
watch us all
emerge you know right pandemic nears an
end but
you lived in new york for years i mean
it's so crazy to just go from
being so used to being in everyone's
personal space to
the complete opposite well you know i
have this experience now i don't know if
you have this but i'll just be watching
tv and movies and people get on subways
yeah and i think oh right remember that
i used to jump on subways
and that just looks insane oh my gosh
that we all used to pack into those
things fully just sardines
yeah in fact the last i have a
horrifying
memory associated with that the last
time i was on a subway in new york
pre-pandemic
i i it was during rush hour
i got on the subway and just
super packed in i was pressed up against
this very tall man
who who he had his back against the edge
of the subway car
and yeah it was one of those
pre-pandemics your face was like pushed
into his chest
fully inside his torso but like no
peripheral vision whatsoever because
there are people like all up
and i had my air pods in i was just like
stay in your lane
be small and just get through this i was
like eight stops away from where i was
going
and i was just in there
a lot of time had passed and finally
after like i was like i think that's
been eight stops
i just remember peeling out of this
i mean i was right i was engulfed by his
chest right like your nose is in his
sternum inside his body yeah and no
one's moving it's so intimate
which again that's just how it was back
pre-pandemic so i was just
so up against his chest finally peeled
out of his body
to see if we're at my destination and
no one was in the subway at that point
like three people everyone had cleared
out
everyone probably probably a while ago
probably
and i i'm like how long was i just
inside this man's body
for absolutely no reason i love the idea
i'm just picturing the completely empty
car and he's there
and you're just and there's no one no
one there's like one lady
20 feet away and i'm just backing out of
the subway looking at him like how could
you not tell me and he was like
that was hilarious yeah just fully and
your
your impression is on his chest yes
you're absolute
please save me from myself why don't you
tell me uh well
yes i can't wait till we get back to
having uh our faces
exchanged more experiences like strange
men's chess um
because i enjoyed that as well uh i want
to talk about this
amazing transformation that you've gone
through to become chad
oh okay chad is a 14 year old boy
yes and it's so funny because if i
didn't know you as the comedic performer
actor that you are and just saw you
i would think this is a very attractive
woman she cannot become a 14 year old
boy it's not going to happen
and i have to say this is
yes this is stunning
[Laughter]
i don't know if i should congratulate
you or what but you really have become
chad
i really can disappear into looking like
a little dude with the right hair and
makeup
hollywood magic man all right well i
just wanted to show you now now chad
has obviously as a lot of 14 year old
boys do
trouble integrating in the world yes
anxieties and i'm just going to say this
is a side by side of me at 14.
i think we would have gotten along very
very well
oh my god that's so good we're we're
both like just a little dead behind the
eyes
yes yeah i never lost that deadness
behind the eyes
we just look like we've been through so
much at this point
don't you see us sitting together in the
cafeteria
at at school and like eating mac and
cheese together and no one is talking to
us
yes like you know when a horse's spirit
is broken that's what we look like
oh i know what a horse's spirit looks
like when it's broken it's
my writers look like that we just you
turned out great so maybe there's hope
for chad yes
yeah you know it's funny because i'm
curious have you had the experience of
walking around as chad i i bring this up
because
the few there have been a few times in
my life when i've been made up for a
sketch
and i had the opportunity to walk around
once i was dressed as a policeman and
it's kind of dangerous to do
because you know but i remembered
walking around
as a policeman and really kind of just
pretending trying to
channel what's it like to be a policeman
of course you know i had a toy
gun and a tin badge but it was kind of
fun
to inhabit that in the real world what
about you have you walked around his
chat
um i have not so much for fun more out
of necessity
like you know when you're shooting
you're so busy doing that if i had like
an hour
off i would be like oh i should just pop
into a grocery store and get that done
so there were a couple times where i was
just like
inside a ralph's with a shopping cart
fully dressed as chad
and was met with legitimate confusion
especially people were far enough to not
know it was a woman you know dressed as
a little boy they were just like why is
this small child
buying so much produce or like they
would just catch i'd be like a full kpop
outfit like
testing the ripeness of avocados like
just no one understood what was going on
yeah i would think and it's yeah it's
probably something they don't associate
a 14 year old boy is not going to be
doing that
very mature too you know if you're if
you're buying any kind of
hairspray or anything yeah feminine
products feminine products i don't know
what those are but i'm told
we have a clip here from chad and uh
i believe this is where you're getting
what looks to be a pretty amazing
pair of sneakers correct anything you
want to add to that or
my real father is in this scene oh
that's right i think he yeah
he fist bumps you he does look for that
the one the guy who just bumps you is
your real
father's acting debut let me let's let's
take a look at the clip and then i want
to ask you about that okay all right
here's a clip from chad
[Music]
are these tissues these are the shoes
what do we do now we are gonna invite
you god damn life change
hey lamb talk oh
yeah lamb talk lamborghini lamb talk uh
[Music]
you know what i'm going to say this he's
not bad and that look he gives to camera
on his line
it's almost like he's a little too into
it we didn't tell him he was going to
have a line because i didn't want him to
get nervous
and we did about 30 takes and he finally
nailed it
and now i'm worried he has the acting
bug and
is going to pursue this professionally
yeah
well step one is does he have a head
shot when your father gets a head shot
there's a lot of on onset stills of my
father that day but he's
i really he's been acting like asking me
about what it would take to join the
union now like i'm so nervous he's going
to get a publicist
and really just go rogue with this but
even on set like
he was amazing but he's not a trained
actor so
i was just nervous he was going to
wander into frame eating a bagel at any
given moment
also i just in the background and look
no sense look at the camera the way like
a horse sometimes does
and just like give a little wink
[Laughter]
i love my my brothers and sisters and my
mother and father but
god i've just the idea of being in a
production
like with my dad any kind of
show business moment with my dad or mom
just two intersecting
yeah i always thought it's like
ghostbusters you can't cross those
you can't cross those streams you've got
to keep them separate yeah a monster is
created
yeah we survived it we survived it and
he's he's great
um and now i think he wants to do this
for a living which i'm horrified by
yeah i saw him just driving around in a
cherry red hummer
license plate star for life you're like
no leaning into it so hard
uh chad airs tuesdays at 10 30 p.m
on tbs and you have to watch it it's
fantastic naseem padrad thank you so
much for being here
in person yeah so great to see you again
i just want to get that spaghetti sauce
let's go i don't know why i feel that
way whenever i see something that white
and pristine
it's tempting yeah yeah well we can now
it's over